pressure is mounting on the Germans the
defense minister Boris Pastorius is on
his way to Ukraine shortly but there's a
danger that all of this Fury around the
challenge of the um leopard two tanks
makes Germany's position look as if
they're just being difficult whereas in
fact the truth is far from that the
reason that German finds himself in this
position is largely linked to history at
the end of the second world war the
Victorious allies uh dismant dismembered
the um German military to make sure that
they could never conduct another war
after two devastating World Wars the
trouble is after that happened literally
very shortly afterwards the Cold War
descended and during the Cold War
Germany found itself on the front line
of that so the allies relented and
allowed Germany to start to build up
some military capability but it was
quite specifically had to be defensive
only and that military couldn't get
involved in internal domestic things it
couldn't end up collecting Intelligence
on German Nationals and most importantly
he couldn't ever have nuclear weapons
and all of that was enshrined in a
Constitution which exists to this day a
the German people for the legacy of
those two two world wars have left a
really difficult dark stain on their
history as a result when the there were
recent polls conducted that showed that
the population of Germany was very
supportive of the German uh position of
providing defensive support to Ukraine
but actually was very very skeptical
about taking that to the offense
particularly the the risks of isolation
and that view was almost certainly made
worse by recent rhetoric from Russia
that has been talking about the
devastating consequences of the arrival
of Western tanks and that's also for a
couple of reasons almost certainly
because they believe that those tanks
will not only be decisive in the battle
but will actually push Russian back if
we move on to the other news today which
was the Russian defense minister Sergey
shogu shown here announced there was
going to be another expansion of the
Russian military up to a three-year plan
going up to 1.5 million uh soldiers
largely in response to their potential
NATO threat allegedly they're looking at
putting another Army group up in the
north here up in Korea on the Finland
border probably because finland's
looking to join NATO and therefore in
response to that threat but most
importantly Putin is also looking to
mobilize his own National Defense
industry he's been doing a whole rafter
meetings with National Defense leaders
all part of a long-term strategy to put
the country on a war footing the
challenge here is what's the West's
response to this largely to date we've
been using what's available to go to
Ukraine whatever and what's required
raiding the war chess of the western
Nations has worked quite well for the
last year but something more robust and
something more proactive would appear to
be required if somebody's going to meet
the requirements of Putin's new
long-term military strategy